We are getting dangerously close to 12000 Dischord
subscribers, which is just insane. Inconceivable.
Let's go first to Josh from Mexico City. Josh,
I would love to hear what's going on there.
Hi, David. Can you hear me?
I can. I can't help but
ask where you are exactly, because it's such a
compelling background noise in the park. You're
at the park. All right. Park in Mexico City. I've
got a picture in my head. What's going on there?
So I had a question for you. It seems
like the the Biden administration,
one of their big things was, was racial
justice. And and since the United Nations
committee on I believe it's unrecognized or
decolonization has specifically called up the US
in terms of its relationship with the
territories and overseas possessions.
Does it seem likely that it also given
that Puerto Rico has more or less
definitively voted on on statehood, if you
can call it that, does it seem likely that
the Biden administration will make a an
attempt to sort of normalize the status of the
of the territories, especially American
Samoa, where they're not where they don't
even have the right to birthright citizenship?
You know, it doesn't strike me that this is
going to be at the top of the list of priorities
for Democrats and for Joe Biden's administration
in these first two years. To me, and this
is not my opinion of what should happen,
I think it should be a priority. It seems to me
that it's more likely to be a sort of 2022 to 2024
priority. And then, of course, you need to wait
and see if Democrats will even have the House
and or Senate. That's my sense right now. I'm
not seeing like a big political appetite for
it. And particularly when the stimulus was going
to be done right away, took months. I'm not super
optimistic it gets done in these first two years.
Sure. Sure.
But thanks. Thanks, David. What are you doing
in Mexico City? Do you do you live there?
Yes. So I'm half Chicano. So I. I
was here working on my Ph.D. before
before lockdown. And so now I live here.
How are things from the standpoint of the virus?
It's complicated. Yeah, the the government has
started to roll out the the Russian vaccine. Yep.
But of course, you have this this is, of course,
a country that's complicated. You know, you could
say it's only been a democracy for the past 20
years. And, you know, you have people you have
the the informal and formal economy. Right. People
who work in the formal economy or are are doing
OK. It's the people who work in the informal
economy that have received no no protection.
Are there ways, if you are an elite, so to speak,
to get the Pfizer or medicine of vaccines there?
What I've what I've what I've heard from some
friends is that people are going to their
summer houses in Florida to get
it right or things of that nature,
that that seems to be the best way to do it.
I've read that about Argentina as well. People,
people who were going to Miami.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's that's pretty much
that's pretty much what's what's happening. And
what's what's what's also interesting is that when
they did the initial contact tracing, they traced
the first case of actually the first cluster of
cases in Mexico City to a group of elites who
who went to Aspen. Oh, really? The currency. Yes.
So not shocking. Not shocking. All right,
Josh, thank you. Appreciate the call.
Yeah. Thank you, David.
All right. There is a Josh
from Mexico City. Let's go next to Sarah from
Washington, D.C.. Sarah, you're on the air.
Hey. Hi. How are you? I'm good. How are you doing?
Well, actually, I never talked to you
before, and I watch everything you do.
And I I'm just honestly here to listen and learn.
Oh, you didn't want to ask a question. I mean,
you know, I'm just listening and here I like
what you do is to listen and take in what I can.
I didn't really have a specific question.
All right. Well, thank you. I appreciate it.
Of course. All right. There we
go. Sarah from Washington, D.C..